[Musique]
passé comme ça quoi
mais visible oui c'était bien visible
mais sur le moment ne savait pas ce qui
se passe est quoi ce que pour la france
mais de l'ombre à goûter en discute que
c'est que ça emmanuel permis journée
même pas fait attention bureau de la
mode support musée du foie un coup de
tonnerre c'est bien c'est pas que la mi
mai après on a vu qu'il y avait quelque
chose d'anormal là le c'est pour ça
qu'on était un jeu david thewlis quoi
oui bien sûr la maison dif noté chose
d'anormal
m
des ovni comme celui ci on en a vu dans
tous les cieux du monde depuis 30 ans
des milliers de rapports des enquêtes se
sont accumulés grâce à cette masse de
renseignements qu'on peut désormais
envisager une étude scientifique du
phénomène ovni ce court documentaire
expose la dernière découverte en date
sur le comportement intelligent de ces
mystérieux engins
elle a pour auteur de chercheurs
dijonnais charles garreau et raymond
lavier pour en suivre le déroulement
il faut revenir en arrière au 7 octobre
1954 à poncer sur lignon un petit
village proche des sources de la seine
madame fourneret alors que s'est il
passé le 7 octobre 1954
mon but c'était le soir il faisait déjà
un peu sombre j'allais fermer les volets
et puis j'ai vu cette boule un peu
lumineuse jaune orange au dessus là
entre l'arbre et puis le toit puis
j'avais l'impression que ça venait
sûrement parce que ça grossit c'est ça
aussi c'est de plus en plus
alors j'ai tout laissé ouvert et j'ai
pris le bébé
je partis chavanne derrière quand on est
rentré au bout d'une heure et ni bref il
cote les hommes sont venus du village
on est allé voir tout ça dans le prix on
a vu les traces comme cela ici par là et
que ressembler cette place elle avait à
peu près à mettre deux ans oui et puis
peut-être 50 cm de large
bien alors tous les bords du trou
s'était creusée par en dessous
et puis alors là l'endroit où que ce qui
est plus d'herbe s'est éparpillé tout le
tour à peu près sur une dizaine de
mètres de l'endroit
alors toutes les modes de terre vous
était au tour oui l herbe est resté
longtemps sans pousser où nous voulons
au moins quatre keller mené par pousser
là debout l'observation vous avez fait
était la première est fait dans la
région ici le nom il y avait les voisins
enfin aux pays voisins me suis même
genex z'avez vu à l'enjeu aussi
longtemps à voir vous même jour trois
jours ou 3 jours 3 jours à bord
maintenant j'ai envie de me trouver là
c'était la forme d'un cylindre et puis
le fils bouyer qui revenait dans le
chemin en huile a vu décoller lui donc
le soir vous l'avez voulu arriver est
arrivé
je ne garde son du pays qui rêvait a vu
leur vol
cet engin longtemps après que vous
l'avez aperçu vous même bien au moins
une heure on vit comme une heure ou une
heure et demie ses traces sin est
relevée à poncer on les retrouvera 13
ans plus tard le 21 avril 1967 en
amérique dans l'état de virginie
une extraordinaire ressemblance un
calque presque parfait
pensée fut la première my insoupçonnées
d'affilée qu'ils arrêtent et ordre sa
trame sur la france entière mais qui
n'apparaîtra que 20 ans plus tard grâce
à l'accumulation des témoignages
recueillis entre temps la seconde my de
cette trame
ce fut marliens près de genlis à
quelques kilomètres de la base de dijon
longvic
nous sommes le 12 mai 1967
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous avez exactement
marque exactement la terre et elle vous
versez y avait comme des du parc loyer
qu'ils savaient faire un effort pour
l'appareil qui était là pour on a
préféré le site t pour se soulever en
l'air quoi c'est pour ça elle remparts
et des disques ou alors à penser que
c'était une soucoupe la terre était
comme la comme c'était un petit peu il
avait chauffé quoi envoyer l'appui on
n'a pas dû conséquent soit sous la
direction du capitaine thepenier la
gendarmerie procède à une enquête
extrêmement minutieuses un hélicoptère
prend des photos verticale qui montre
bien l'empreinte en étoile matérialiser
à la chaux des croquis sont faits les
trous d'ancrage du système
d'atterrissage sont dessinés copté quand
le rapport est terminée on s'aperçoit
qu'il correspond exactement à celui qui
a été établie en 1965 par les gendarmes
de digne dans les basses alpes lors de
l'atterrissage de valensole ainsi cette
similitude parfaite entre les troupes de
marliens et de valensole un an plus tard
le 21 juin 1968 ces brasiers en morvan
il est environ 11h 30
le temps était couvert j'étais avec deux
camarades lundi passé vers moi et que
les ricains il ya univers là bas
direction nord-nord-est n'est ce pas qui
qui nous paraît vraiment bizarre les cas
tirer vraiment notre vue quoi si c'était
si cette chose qui est vraiment insolite
alors on la fixe et on assister cette
lueur et environs au bout de deux
minutes
l'annuaire à diminuer progressivement et
au même endroit
nous avons perçu un objet enfin objets
qui semblaient talange un quelconque
d'une
une folle mais est vraiment rien connu
quoi je ne pouvais pas du tout par
exemple identifier avec une voiture ou
en avion ou toute chose comme ça ne soit
bon et le l'engin avait l'air de planer
un peu avant de se poser à terre le
jeune marc joly lui voyait même mieux
que nous ils nous disaient qu'il y avait
une surface de soug était un peu un peu
noir alors que le dessus et elle a un
blanc un blanc vraiment immaculé et
alors moi ça m'a toujours intéressé au
bout de quelques minutes de son parti
moi je suis toujours resté mais tout en
piochant époque de terre je t'ai tout
même à coup d'oeil d'abord sur l'engin
au bout d'une vingtaine de minutes j'ai
constaté qu'ils avaient disparu j'ai
toujours 6es et quelques minutes après
il s'est produit à flash comme un flash
photographiquement fin d'une intensifs
et intensité assez forte le spa rouge et
je me suis dit bas l'engin a disparu
alors monsieur michaud vous avez fini
par localiser cet endroit où nous sommes
actuellement
oui nous sommes ici je lui
d'atterrissage nous avons trouvé une
bille qui était payée au pied de dupuy
table qu'il aborde
il y avait sept morts sud et des ions
indépendamment des deux qui ont jamais
été le plus et les deux buts me berton
on avait remarqué aussi que
principalement là bas vers le bois les
limaces était d'une couleur assez brune
alors qu'ici dans notre région elles
sont plutôt rose et piano le rouge mais
enfin prendre une
et alors que j'en avais récupérer enfin
une dizaine qui avait envoyé aux
professionnels lautier et d'après
l'analyse y avait quand même une
évaluation aussi de ses deux buts enfin
on appelle des suppliques aux
modélisations enfin le nom mais je parie
scientifique et moi même à la suite de
cet incident j'ai vachement arrivée la
maison ma femme m'a dit mais qu'est ce
que tu as dans les yeux j'avais des yeux
toulouse etc
j'ai dit bon ben j'ai reçu des rayons
vins
jean-jacques ont aperçu la mort et j'ai
eu des brûlures dans l'épiné dorsale
pendant un mois qu'ils prenaient
toujours de cette irradiation brazès est
l'élément déterminant car en étudiant
quelques années plus tard les
atterrissages qui se sont produits en
côte d'or et en reportant ceux de poncer
marliens et braz et sur une carte aux
200 millièmes raymond aviez découvre que
marc liens et braz et sont tous deux
disent temps de 43 km 202 penser et que
deux plus les lignes marliens poncet et
braz et poncé sont perpendiculaires
c'est le point de départ d'une étude qui
va porter sur les quelques 200
atterrissage signalés en france depuis
le premier d'entre eux près de rouen en
juillet 1947 première opération reporter
tous ces atterrissages sur cartes aux
200 millièmes avec la plus grande
précision possible en faisant appel au
rapport de la gendarmerie seconde
opération reporter ses points sur la
carte au millionième en projection
coniques de l'hygiène puis en établir un
calque
enfin à partir du triangle braz et poncé
marliens crasse et un quadrillage de 4
cm 32 deux côtés on voit de suite qu'un
pourcentage élevé l'atterrissage se
situe sur ces couloirs dont la largeur
réelle au sol peut être estimé à 500
mètres phénomène particulièrement
remarquables en bourgogne franche comté
une nouvelle étape dans cette voie de
recherche allait être franchie en
comparant cette trame aux travaux des
chercheurs néo-zélandais en étudiant les
observations dans cette partie du monde
le capitaine bruce katy avait constaté
qu'elle se situait sur un quadrillage de
33 milles marins qui l'avait baptisé
harmonique 33 et qui correspond à un
carré de 61 km 116 de côté or en
comparant cette trame à la trame lavier
on découvre que la superposition et
parfaite que le premier quadrillage des
autres que des diagonales d'harmoniques
33 la superposition des deux trames
amène une autre constatation bon nombre
d atterrissage qui ne se trouvait pas
sur les diagonales se situe sur
harmonique 33 près de 80% au total
pourcentage qui a augmenté depuis deux
ans 6h38 atterrissage signalé 33 ont eu
lieu sur ce quadrillage soit près de 90
%
d'où la possibilité d'une nouvelle étape
dans la proche du phénomène ovni
la mise en place d'un réseau de
détecteurs sur les couloirs qui
paraissent les plus fréquentés c'est ce
que prévoit le groupe géraud de besançon
qui achève la mise au point d'une
véritable station de repérage vous avez
un appareil perfectionner ici c'est une
station
alors ce qu'une station qui est en cours
d'élaboration qui comporte au point de
vue détection le système magnétique
différent ici qui donneront déjà une une
idée de l'orientation de ce champ
magnétique perturbateur de de
l'intensité à ça on a associé une
détection des infrasons parce qu'on a
constaté aussi que dans certains cas les
ovnis et générait des infrasons face à
ses puissants
ce qui donne une sorte de bourdonnement
c'est à la limite de des sons audibles
alors donc au point de vue capteurs nasa
on a une liaison qui se fait par un
câble jusqu'à la station alors sur la
station elle-même on aura ici des
voyants qui correspondront aux alarmes
des différents capteurs on aura une
alarme sonore bien sûr des interrupteurs
de commandes
ici on a une base de temps à quartz qui
donne une bonne précision pour
l'indication horaire des phénomènes
ici on aura un fréquencemètre qui
permettra de mesurer la fréquence des
perturbations magnétiques ou infrasons
ainsi peu à peu des pièces nouvelles
sont versés au dossier des mystérieux
zone
la question de leur existence ne se pose
plus un double point d'interrogation
subsiste encore passionnant et
inquiétant tout à la fois
d'où vient-il et pourquoi vient-il
[Musique]